[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up is we're going to censor the
shocking claims that have rocked the
world of Show Business movie star turned
New Media Messiah his words Russell
Brand is accused of rape and sexual
abuse is he facing a trial by media the
TV Executives turn a blind eye to a
sexual predator why are so many
including the world's richest man Elon
Musk calling it all a conspiracy
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening London welcome to Piers Morgan
on sensible the allegations made against
Russell Brand are shocking and there is
no question that the investigative
journalism behind them from the Sunday
Times in Channel Falls dispatches
program was both meticulous and Powerful
bran has been accused of rape sexual
assault and emotional abuse by four
women when he's at the height of his
Fame he's also accused of grooming a 16
year old girl who says she was taken
from school to his home in a car paid
for by the BBC
he's grabbing at my my underwear pulling
it to the side I'm telling him to get
off me and he won't get off
he grabbed me and got me on the bed I
was fully clothed and he was naked at
this point and he held me down and he
was just aggressively trying to you know
me I was like oh my God
he raped me
so a BBC chauffeur driven car picked you
up at the age of 16 to take you to
Russell Brown's house yes he told me
that his management had told him his
agent not to be seen out enough
management had advised him not to be
seen out and about with a 16 year old
yeah because they said it wasn't a good
look for him and for his career
well these are obviously horrifying
claims and if they're all true then Bram
will deserve every punishment meet it
out to him but at this stage they remain
claims and Russell Brand has vehemently
denied them whatever you think of him
he's entitled to Due Process every bit
as much as his accusers deserve to be
taken seriously these are grave criminal
accusations which now demand a police
investigation to determine if they meet
the legal bar for charges prosecution
and a possible trial but some of the
language we're seeing online including
from many journalists describing the
accusers as victims and survivors
employers that Brand's already been
convicted of a crime when he hasn't the
court of public opinion is not an actual
court but it behaves like one and that's
inherently dangerous as we saw with the
likes of Sir Cliff Richard who was
wrongly accused of sexual assault has
exemplary public reputation destroyed in
the process until you want a legal
action against the BBC and cleared his
name
the consequences of the accusations are
already apparent Brands book deals been
shelved his tour has been postponed his
management team has dropped him Clips
like this about him are going viral
at the start of the year that you were
considering attempting celibacy is that
something that you have continued with
what time do you finish work
you're ever so confused Fifi box pop
yourself down on my knee and see if we
can't get you pregnant
come on oh my God
thank you well it's been really a one
such thing
how can I do your bra just like this
oh
well but today is stricter moral code
after the metoo movement and time's up
campaign it's easy to watch all that and
be appalled by Russell Brand's apparent
immorality this is not referendum on his
moral compass by his own regular
admission he was an outrageously
promiscuous sex addict who reveled in
his ancestor womanizing brand openly
boasted about it he was saluted for it
by many in the media it didn't stop BBC
News night using him as a Biblical
Svengali it didn't stop the guardian
giving him top billing on stage with
Owen Jones and Publishing his column for
many years it didn't stop Ed miliband
seeking his endorsement of prime
minister it didn't stop the new states
by making him a guest editor nor
Prospect magazine naming him the fourth
most influential thinker in the world
Channel 4 the BBC and a series of media
Executives will have serious questions
to answer if it turns out that Russell
Brand has indeed been the ruthless
predatory criminal that these new
allegations suggest so with all those
righteous Publications who made him a
demigod
what we cannot do is preemptively
convict a man of hina's crimes like this
without any legal due process to
establish the cold hard facts
joining me to discuss all this is
comedian Samantha presti political
journalist Ava Santina and talk to the
contributor Esther cracker all right
I've seen both of you two all over
social media since this story broke so
let me start with you Esther you've been
pretty strong he said there's nothing
stunning and brave about choosing to sit
down with a journalist instead of going
to the police and someone who does that
is definitely not interested in Justice
only public sympathy yeah I was quite a
shocked when I read that oh yes because
the thing is ultimately what are the
publics supposed to do we cannot have
this man hung drawn and courted we are
not a court we are not we you know the
legal process is invested in us if these
claims which are outrageous and they
sound very serious obviously you should
go to the police and it's not just about
these victims but it's also protecting
other women as well I hate this this
binary where we have that oh we're
supposed to believe all women women are
strong and empowered but on the other
hand you know when you don't go to the
police you get to have it both ways
where you can have someone not convicted
in a court but you can have them what
about the argument that only one percent
of rape cases
that's more of a reason to try and
improve the system but it might be more
of a reason why a lot of women choose
actually a different avenue but you
can't get Justice and they may I
mentioned the two campaigns me too and
time's up of course you know it was down
to journalists that people like Harvey
Weinstein ended up in prison yeah but
they were the ones that investigated
this is the difference between a
journalist and a a lawyer or someone who
works in the criminal um justice system
they are looking for facts a a
journalist has looked no no I'm sorry
there have been many sorry there have
been many journalists who have failed at
their job because they're looking for a
story they're looking for a scoop at the
end of the day I have far more trust in
the legal system as slow and clunky as
it may be and in legal professionals and
I do in a journalist that's looking for
their labor I mean I read the I read you
know I think with all these things the
best thing to do is sit down and read
every word and then I watch the whole of
dispatches and I thought it was
extremely thorough journalism meticulous
obviously very carefully legaled I felt
as a former newspaper editor myself I
know how complicated these things to be
uh so I thought that from a journalistic
point of view there wasn't much more
they could have done to present the
cases of four different women none of
whom apparently knew each other uh all
making very serious allegations but my
issue with the waste played out on
social media when people talk regularly
on Twitter or whatever about victims and
survivors in relation to these women at
the moment they're accusers
they're not actually at the moment
established to be victims and survivors
and tillarifts there is some kind of
criminal action am I wrong okay well
Park the Russell Brand thing just to
give you an example that is not
connected to that at all I'll ask you
about Jimmy Savile we've all made up our
mind about Jimmy Savile he was never
convicted in a court should we all
change our minds now I think the court
of public opinion has been quite funny
well he died but he was never tried in
the course I'm sorry
organizations admitted admitted to
actually covering up his crimes I'm
sorry there have been there has been
corroborating evidence there the issue
here is I'm sorry you can't make that
argument the issue here is this is an
episode of he said she said if he's
denied it and we can't do anything about
it what exactly are we supposed to I
think your opinion sucks on this no I'm
sorry
well I'm sure you would um look I think
you know Russell Brands is an extremely
litigious individual okay libel law in
the UK means that it is far easier to
basically say oh this newspaper has hurt
my feelings and therefore I can see you
then you have to provide a wealth of
evidence it will be far more strange far
more wealth of evidence than actually
even the quarterback but are you
comfortable with the way the court of
public opinion has already convicted in
many cases
do you know I think I mean put another
way I'm as uncomfortable with that as I
am with all the people trying to claim
there's some vast conspiracy theory and
he's being taken out by mainstream media
because of some thing to do with his
YouTube channel I think that's complete
nonsense right I have a problem with
both extremities here but I do think
there's a real danger we saw it with
Cliff Richard we saw it with this young
man I interviewed a few months ago who
was a victim of a total fantasist who
ended up doing two months on remand had
rapists dogs all over his his home wall
all completely the result of a fantasies
now I'm not saying that that's the case
here they might all be absolutely
telling the truth it's certainly very
compelling and convincing I thought the
reporting but they remain allegations
he's entitled every single newspaper and
broadcaster has reported they said they
are accusations and allegations and
there was no business does any woman
have coming out now to say that those
women should not be believed instead we
should all
no no again I have a big problem with
what you just said when you say
automatically believed right I have a
problem with that I think all accusers
who make allegations this series they
should be listened to taken seriously
and then their claims should be properly
investigated by law enforcement right
that's the only way to deal with
criminal allegations the moment you have
a presumption that everyone who makes
claims like this has to be believed you
end up with problems like do you
remember the the fantasist you had all
the politicians right
but every example that you can give
there will be 100 000 women who have had
a sexual assault claim that has been bit
off by the police that is also wrong but
that doesn't change my point which is
you can't automatically believe accusers
you have to investigate them so the
moment you use that language I you lose
me a bit because I'm like hang on hang
on well what if there's a young girl
the young girl at home who wants to make
an allegation like this you say you will
be respected you'll be listened to you
will have your full story taken down you
will have all that right what you won't
be is automatically believed because if
the moment you do that you allow what
happened with this fantasist with this
poor boy you know this 18 year old boy
life ruined by complete fantasies these
things will happen if you have a
presumption of that now let me bringing
you uh some matter if I may you you had
a brief sort of well not not really a
romance for Russell but you had a
something with it right yeah it had a
little encounter back in 2006 I went to
his flat we had a little bit of a fumble
we got to Crunch point and I'm like no
and you're a comedian yeah and I wasn't
back then I was a model and a dancer and
um yeah so he was fine with me he was
really polite and I felt safe with him
so and when you said you didn't want to
go any further how how was he then he
was fine
there was no problem at all
um everything that happened was
consensual so when I'm reading these
stories it it doesn't represent my
experience now I'm not saying that you
know a rapist an alleged rapist would
would treat the same women all women the
same way but that's not my only
experience of Russell Brandon but it
said on the comedy circuit this was
widely known yeah no I don't Russell
Brand 20 years from it I've interviewed
him with my life story so I've
interviewed in Virginia many many times
Russell Brand I was actually texting
with him a few weeks ago about
potentially doing an interview right so
I've known him a long time and I I was
shocked when I read this because I've
Heard lots of rumors about lots of
people over the years but actually most
of it has turned out to be nonsense yeah
here to read it actually laid out was
shocking if it is true it's shocking
Behavior this is why it jars so much
with me because I've been in the comedy
world since 2014 and then in 2015 I was
very
um involved in a political campaign that
Russell Brand was leading and he was
helping women
um keep their social homes so and you've
never heard any rumors nobody said to me
oh be careful around Russell Brand I
drove a van that had the truth on this
side it advertised his Cafe he was doing
a lot of good work so I got to know him
as an activist and a good man
um so you know I'm not going to
automatically believe Anonymous people
coming forward especially having been in
the entertainment industry my whole life
and knowing how manipulative and
narcissistic some people in the sense
some people I think I think there's a
real teaching moment here because I I
don't know Russell Brand I've never met
him but he is admitted to have slept
with thousands of women yeah and I think
that's where the issue is because if you
were a man or women but I was speaking
the case of Russell Brand and you have
been intimate with thousands of women
it's not difficult to find a handful of
women that have felt they've had a
negative disrespectful like talking
about an allegation of rape no but for
women with allegations I'm I'm not sure
I think it's one allegation promiscuous
degenerate it's not surprising that at
some point allegations of sexuality what
about the wider issue here which is that
um they're all Anonymous these accusers
Brands obviously been named his name is
currently you know going through the
Mensa
um front page of every paper for the
worst possible allegations is it right
that his accusers should retain
anonymity I think we can all say that
it's been an absolute sewer over social
media for the past couple of days until
you imagine but only aim to him but can
you imagine the danger that those women
would have been put in you've also got
to think about the financial difference
between these two people okay Russell
Brand is the product of you know
Hollywood films big TV shows he's got
money behind it
himself about his children what about
the woman
right allegedly
better than you guys right and he has a
right to the Assumption of Innocence at
the end of the day listen I don't know
this man I have never I'm not interested
in any of his work or any of that but
there are wider implications of assuming
his guilt and we're already seeing
what's happening to his career as a
result of it I know you may not feel
sympathy because you you automatically
assume that these women are right fine
but the bigger point is here we don't
have a right to make that judgment and
by going to the media instead of the
police I'm very skeptical of these women
because they chose to remain well hang
on again look let me play Devil's
Advocate again I think that it is highly
likely they will now go to the police
well I have to see it to believe it I
mean let's wait and see it's also
possible that other women as I believe
the times have now been saying other
women are coming forward whose stories
will also have to be investigated so we
don't really know at a very early stage
of this they drop this massive bombshell
but it is interesting to me that all the
accusers remain among Anonymous so so
whatever happens if their stories end up
in some way being disproven by Russell
Brand their names never come out whereas
his name is now completely destroyed by
this whatever happens I just don't I
just think that's a there's no way that
you could have put those women's names
into the newspapers this weekend they
would have been heckled and to high hell
it would have been awful for them you
just can't but I remember Rose McGowan
for example going public about Harvey
wife look what happened to her well yes
but I interviewed her but she and she
was incredibly courageous and she did
get a lot of you know terrible Fallout
from it but by being I think going on
the record it did help to incarcerate
him it'll never come out of prison
almost highly probably because of what
she said then I would argue that if
these these women has gone to the police
first the police would have said these
are historical incidents you can't
actually prove them in a court of law
and they would have biffed them out the
door anyway so and then which is also
possible I mean that is possible and
then if we were sitting here around this
panel and we've been fighting it's
important to encourage women to speak
out I don't like this sort of you know
innocent Wallflower at the approach we
have to women actually reporting to the
police because it's not just about them
it's also about protecting other women
I'm sorry I've had friends who've been
raped and I said this is bigger than you
because this person can go go and do
this other woman it's about having
something on the record right that one
of the victims went to a Rape Crisis
Center but she didn't call 9-1-1 to
report it meanwhile she had evidence at
the time it happened allegedly and she
could have gone to the police and it
would have been on the record imagine if
other women had had that
in compassion though that for perhaps if
something that serious happens to you
the last thing you want to do is
have two men around your house
I don't have it both ways you cannot
choose to be quiet and then 10 years
later oh by the way I was me three I'm
just here is my story there is
compassion for the women I have a sleuth
of compassion but guess what I also have
a sense of compassion with alleged
victims who were not protected because
these women didn't go to the police
their actions have consequences I'm
sorry and we need to tell women I mean
that is that is a valid point isn't it
yeah you don't if you don't go to the
police you're in danger actually in a
way you're allowing a rapist if that's
indeed what Russell Brand you're
allowing that person to continue doing
what they're doing the police in this
country this country clean up their act
then because if you're going to turn up
at a police Center and they're going to
throw your evidence can I just finish
the point
like someone's evidence in a fridge that
doesn't work and you're gonna have to
speak to bill in Bolton who doesn't
really care or someone potentially like
Wayne cousins in the met there is no
incentive for a woman to go there it's
not my experience I have I have been
raped and I did go to the police the
first time and I had to go take the
swabs that I had to do all of that stuff
um it it wasn't a horrible experience
going to the police the man was arrested
what happened to that man well he said
that I consented so that was it it went
to the crown prosecution service and
they said well it will be your word
against his in court it's not that we
don't believe you but we've now got this
on record if he does it to anyone else
so that kind of backs up your point it
was hard to do that okay but I never
thought once that oh I want to go to the
Press why would I want to put myself in
such an unsafe environment yes believe
women in in a therapeutic setting in a
personal setting but you can't just go
into the mass media and and expect to be
believed well I mean I would say again
I'd come back to Harvey Weinstein uh not
somebody else I knew well and he was
taken down by women who went to the
media by journalists from The New York
Times and by Ronald Barrow and others
who were involved in that it was
journalists that took down Harvey
Weinstein so you know journalism can be
a very powerful tool in holding powerful
people to account uh we've got to move
on we're going to extend the story for
us to say thank you very much to my
panel I appreciate it and says the next
the sax Gate scandal got Russell Brown
five from the BBC and began his Ascent
to Global Fame and now infamy the woman
at the heart of that Scandal and who
SATs his granddaughter joins me in the
studio next
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to peers organizers sax
gate was the Scandal that made Russell
Brand notorious or Georgina Bailey the
granddaughter of 40 Towers star Andrew
Sachs was in a relationship with Brown
when she was 20 and he was 30. brown was
fired after he and his BBC Radio 2
co-host Jonathan Ross left vulgar
messages on Andrew Sax's voicemail
bragging that brand has slept with his
granddaughter
look Andrew Sachs I've got respect for
you annual lineage and progeny never let
that be questions hint I want hinting
what
do you know what you're doing
now
[Laughter]
Andrew sax I did not do nothing with
Georgina oh no I've revealed I know my
name oh
disaster
well the BBC received more than 40 000
complaints radio 2's controller quit
over the scan the brown was fired I'm
joined in the studio now by Andrew Sax's
granddaughter Georgina Bailey Jordan I
can see almost coiling in horror
listening to that again because it was I
remember listening to that and thinking
hey I thought it was disgusting and B I
couldn't believe that it had been edited
and put out it wasn't like this would
have been taped and then put out by the
BBC exactly what was it like for you to
be caught in that storm
well it wasn't pleasant
um I was very young at the time I was 23
years old when the story broke and it
was a very unnerving time because not
only have my grandparents heard about
what I've been up to sexually which
anybody would recoil yeah
um but then it's all the boys will be
boys attitude and like oh isn't it funny
she's only she's a
anyway so like who cares
um so that was their only line of
defenses to sort of Shame me basically
obviously their behavior was appalling
and everyone agreed with that how did
Russell treat you when you were actually
in a relationship well first of all I I
don't I wouldn't consider me and Russell
having been in a relationship we had
like a sort of Friends with Benefits
type situation which was fine in my
early 20s
um and he was always very nice to me
like he it was very clear what the
parameters of the relationship were
um and that was mutually agreed upon and
um never did anything untoward happen
and he later right and obviously that
came and that was shocking but later a
few years later he did actually help pay
for you to go through rehab yes exactly
so
um I was struggling with addiction for
about 10 15 years and um I I was finding
it very hard to get to clean and sober
so
um one of my mutual friends between me
and Russell called him up and said you
know George you need some help and so he
sent me to rehab and I I was physically
separated from my drug of choice and I
got some therapy and I think that had a
big part to play in my recovery Journey
um and he looked me in the eyes and he
made his amends to me which is what we
do in recovery we have to make amends to
people what did he say to you he just
acknowledged that it was a private
relationship and it shouldn't have been
made public and that at the time he had
two daughters and I think that it really
made him grow and change and um yeah he
he I felt it was genuine I felt that he
was sorry so we cut for this was 2018 so
we cut forward five years now he's all
over the front pages of every paper as
an alleged rapist and sexual abuser what
was your reaction when you first heard
about this
um so initially
first of all I have been a survivor of
sexual abuse okay and
I will always believe victims because
why wouldn't you would you always
believe accusers
accusers it it depends I wasn't in the
room you know we weren't in the room we
don't know what happened there
um but my initial thought was oh my God
I'm glad I'm not Russell
because it's it's
it's behavior that he was doing when he
wasn't well so when you're an addict you
can cross addict so if you're not
working a program he explained this to
me when he made his amends you can be
off booze and drugs but if you're not
working a program you can be acting out
on a sex addiction or a food addiction
and he wasn't working a program and as
an addict in recovery I know that he
wasn't well so I have to that doesn't
justify it doesn't raped and sexual
assault it really it does not if indeed
that is what he did I mean I've read
I've only read what I've read I've seen
the dispatches program they are
disturbing allegations but they are
allegations do you I mean do you
recognize the person described in these
reports no
I don't but I'm not saying that they're
lies because
um you know it was a long time ago we
all and I think they should be believed
um and get some help because part of the
recovery program is you must make amends
for these things and that's what he did
to me and hopefully he'll do the same
for the others you're presuming he's
guilty I'm
and I wouldn't say that I would say that
I'm I'm taking it in with a pinch of
salt maybe for want of a better would it
not be better now if this becomes a
police investigation to try and
determine whether these allegations are
in fact of course legally sound of
course yeah
have you spoken to Russell about any of
this no I haven't
um do you want to call him do you feel
that way or do you want to keep out of
it
um to be honest you know all I've got is
my own truth and
yeah I I don't I don't know what I would
say to him I mean it's not a journey of
being with him he's sort of ruined well
you had a nice time with him then he
sort of ruined your life for a bit then
he saved your life potentially by
helping you with the rehab it's been
quite a journey between the two yeah
what are your feelings towards them
today well I feel like
he was a different person
during those times he was young and
stupid and as was I and um things would
have been done differently now I think
um shaming was totally fine back
then and uh so I was amazing Target but
um sorry what was the question well just
just what your thought your thoughts
towards him are right I I want him to
continue on his path of recovery and
when he makes a mistake making amends
that's what we do at the moment he's
categorically deny these allegations I
hear that
yeah but when you read when you read the
reports you think that maybe Merit to
what these girls are saying these women
are saying I from my own personal
experience do you not see Russell as a
rapist
um however
a lot of the the evidence is very
compelling so
one has to keep an open mind
what are you doing now with your life oh
that's a big question yeah um so I'm an
artist I paint mainly
um and I do big commissions for people
and I also am an actress and I had the
lead role in a play last year two years
ago and also I have a little TV series
called Fanny business in which I play a
50s housewife who's a bit insane and you
you I hope you don't mind me saying you
said you've been clean now for a number
of years I've been clean and sober for
three and a three and a half years I'll
be turning four on February 16th so
you're in a good place I would say so
yeah I'm glad to hear that because I
think what you went through in that sex
Gate scandal was yeah it was a bit
rubbish I thought it was just a terrible
way to treat a young woman uh really was
and very unacceptable so I'm glad to see
you doing well best of luck to you thank
you very much good to see you on
Thursday next are newspapers and
documentaries the right place for the
serious allegations of Russell Brand
faces top lawyer Chris dorkey KC so they
could make a fair trial impossible he'll
be here to debate that next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
Kinfolk do you believe you can win this
war it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about let me once NHS manages to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
way TK team that would make her a better
princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I obviously wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election can we yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
Rest the results
thank you
let it roll
[Music]
producing oil the knock-on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
I know you're probably going to vote me
after church
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air
thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
when I'm in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drug you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
talk about Russell Brands tonight all
allegations against and released a video
on Friday denouncing aggressive media
outlets in anticipation of the claims
I've received two extremely disturbing
letters or a letter and an email one
from a mainstream media TV company one
from a newspaper listing a Litany of
extremely egregious and aggressive
attacks but amidst this Litany of
astonishing rather Baroque attacks are
some very serious allegations that I
absolutely refute there are witnesses
whose evidence directly contradicts the
narratives that these two mainstream
media Outlets are trying to construct
apparently in what seems to me to be a
coordinated attack
with allegations against brand are
serious and of course potentially
criminal it's the media though the right
place for that debate joining me now is
Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine lawyer
Chris door KC and Associates of Amira
Kevin McGuire welcome to all of you
Sarah are you fired up a column very
quickly which I completely concurred
with which is whatever you think of
Russell Brand and you were pretty
scathing about your character assessment
of him it doesn't change the fact that
like everybody in this country in a
Democratic Society you should be
entitled to Due Process absolutely 100 I
mean because we've seen this happen with
lots of people where things are said
their careers are destroyed and then you
know turns out five years later they
haven't done any of the stuff that was
that they were accused or they've done
some of it but not all of it and it
wasn't quite as bad as it looked and I
mean I I've never liked Russell Brand I
always thought she was a bit of a
scumbag you know I would never have got
I wouldn't have even gotten a lift with
him let alone gone to his house or done
anything with him because it was clear
here he was always people keep saying
that he was hiding in plain sight I
don't think he was at all he was okay
obviously not very nice I interviewed
him multiple times and he was pretty
open yeah about his love of having sex
with as many women as possible yeah and
you know he was like the question here
is has he strained into criminality well
that's the thing and that and that and
that is going to be when you know that
is what needs to be established he needs
to have a fair Hearing in a a not in a
sort of feverish and media environment
with people tweeting and all this kind
of stuff that is no way to determine a
person's guilt or anything well my issue
with it Kevin is that when you have
language on social media calling the
people who made the allegations victims
and survivors you are prejudging his
criminal guilt you're saying that all
these allegations are true they are
victims of a crime but we're not at that
stage yet we're at the stage that of
allegation reported in media and I I do
have a problem with that I think we've
got to be very careful about languages
used yeah they're alleged uh victims
they are his accusers that's what they
are and I I hope I hope it does end up
in court so it can all be tested and it
gets due process now whether it does or
not I don't know and you mentioned
earlier fewer than one percent of
reported rapes end up in a conviction
and the victims who do get their day in
court have to wait more than two years
for their Justice I think the Sunday
Times the times shallow thoughts
fantastic public interest investigative
journalism that is incredibly forensic
they will have gone through legal
illegal hoop you know that that's a four
years
I read it with my old newspaper editor
hat on and I thought it was an exemplary
investigation they have given a voice to
women yeah who for whatever reason felt
they wouldn't get anywhere with the
police yeah now he he and as I said he
lies everything Harvey Weinstein is in
prison because women went to journalists
right so let's be clear journalism plays
a very powerful role in a lot of these
cases so I don't agree with all the
Press bashing I think the Sunday Times
dispatches Did very professionally and
thoroughly however Chris that doesn't
mean to say that the allegations are
true as a lawyer as a KC when you're
looking at the way this is all playing
out how concerned are you about Russell
Brandt's ability to get a fair trial
well I don't think you could make this
up but we're actually we're here in a
television Studio analyzing in public
the behavior of somebody through the
lens of media reporting by a different
media Outlet this this for me the
problem here is not about fairness or
otherwise of Trials because the reality
is I suspect based on what I've seen
it's highly improbable that he'll face
trial at least in England well for a
number of reasons one because of the
lack of credible evidence in in the
criminal and forensic sense of the word
two because of the passage of time and
three and this is the really the real
Crux of this debate
um the the dangers of all of this
prejudicial publicity there has been so
much publicity which is so damaging and
so negative and If This Were a live
criminal investigation in law as you
know better than I do all of you know as
journalists you couldn't say any of
these things it's not it's contempt of
court but it's not is it it's not it's
not and that's always it's always been
the reason why papers to this point can
continue to investigate and publish on a
slightly different legal point a lot of
people have said to me in the case of
the 16 year old girl and he was 30. yes
legally no crime appears to have been
committed in that particular instance
potentially grooming I guess I mean
there may be some laws which could
pertain to that aspect but is it right
some people are asking the 16 year old
girl could give consent in that
situation is it time to look at the law
of consent and raise it the age of
consent no no I don't I don't if she can
get married at 16. yeah well you can get
married join the Army at 16 but and so
for so limited purpose but does that
case raise any issues for you listen I'm
not going to speak about the facts of an
individual allegation because I think
that's the exact mistake that too many
people are getting into particularly
lawyers who should know better okay I
can't comment on the allegations
themselves but so far as the idea that a
30 year old man can have a consensual
relationship with a 16 year old young
woman the law says that I don't think
it's I I don't think it's a subject I
know enough about but but I would say
that frankly the age of consent is
possible you're not a lawyer
but I'd say it was morally pretty
reprehensible but I mean I mean I just
don't think we're here judge Russell
Brand from a moral standpoint the sense
of well he may not have the same moral
compass as the rest of us
um but that's not what he did we're
judging him really on whether his his
morals have led him to commit crimes
against his women which is what they've
alleged but also these but these crimes
are very very one of the reasons that so
few uh rape allegations go to court is
because they are very difficult to prove
aren't they listen I think the big story
here that we should be talking about and
Kevin alluded to this earlier on is
women cannot get Justice when they're
raped in this country women cannot get
Justice if they're sexually assaulted in
this country because the system doesn't
have the resource to cope with even five
percent so wouldn't that be their
response to you saying this is all
playing out in the media isn't that why
they've gone to the meeting no I I well
they know I'm not criticizing the
individual women who went to the media
that's inside but almost by your own
admission where else can they go that
the legal system is so flawed you make a
good point but that's what we should be
talking about we are no we're not really
we're talking about I'm literally
talking about it no no we are talking I
mean we the country the media as a whole
have become obsessed with Russell Brand
we're not habitually talking about the
flaws in our justices
let me I'll pick you up on that because
we're talking about Russell Brad He's a
major celebrity he's a Hollywood star
what's that significant well then why
are you a problem
part of celebrity culture that's why
we're talking about it but also he's a
powerful guy who's held down positions
at top networks like the BBC which are
publicly he's not Harvey Weinstein
though is he in terms of we don't know
do we well no in terms of power within
the within the industry oh actually I
would say Russell Brand has held a lot
of respect you must you must accept
there is a difference in the Public's
attention and interest if there's an
allegation made it's an allegation
against somebody who's incredibly
prominent as in somebody who lives in
leads on Luton you've never heard of
course
a Common Thread I think where we may
find agreement here is if you look at
the this this year's been Phillip
Schofield Hugh Edwards now Russell Brown
all different stories but all massive
scandals involving very big celebrity
figures news people and so on
um but the common theme is they've all
been convicted in the court of public
opinion and um and by jury of social
media and that to me seems to be a
problem it did when I ran the Daily
Mirror for example social media didn't
exist hang on hang on some people have
been some found not guilty there are
people who like uh Russell Brand's views
and his conspiracy theories so they say
oh he's a victim of another question
I'm going to come to that part of this
in a different part of the show because
I find that ridiculous the idea that
people are promoting this Theory a lot
of high profile people are that somehow
because Russell Brand does this YouTube
channel in which he goes down conspiracy
theory roots that that he's going to be
silenced I think he's for the birds but
I mean the thing about if you think
about other people who have been accused
the only people who have managed to
prove their innocence really properly
are the ones who've got very very very
deep pockets and who can and very good
lawyers okay and very very good lawyers
and it's very difficult for ordinary
people and and to be honest this does
happen to Ordinary People doesn't it
it's not just the celebrities almost
always it does happen you know basically
if you want to ruin someone's life
accuse them of something like this and
and they they they don't it happens to I
mean I've watched Russell I watch
Russell Brown's video right it happens
and like I said I've done Russell Brand
20 odd years right I was trying to get
him for an interview until this blew up
um I I watched his video and I saw a guy
I mean he was absolutely adamant right
I've been sent these allegations any
suggestion it was non-consensual
I utterly refute now there is some
evidence that the papers have already
produced in dispatches text messages and
so on and who knows what else they've
got which I'm told by other lawyers is
but materially very important because
even though there's a Timeless evidence
because it's contemporaneous so he will
be judged accordingly on that but it's
very difficult like like Sarah said if
you're Russell Brand how do you this is
a tsunami
shutting down your life and your his
wife pregnant he's all tall he's got a
bit Suddenly It's it's all gone right
he's flamed away
my only question really is
is this right that our society does this
in the way that we're doing it
like you it's not right all in different
cases it's not right here's but it's far
worse that tens and tens of thousands of
women are raped in this country and
hardly any media coverage about it and
hardly any resource put into support
that's much worse than three celebrities
being falsely accused if that's what's
happening that's a pin prick in terms of
sexual offenses and sexual violence in
this country it's an irrelevance
to be fair in every one of those cases
all the revelations from the newspapers
May well turn out to have been
completely accurate right so I don't is
it I'm not in any way trying to impugn
the veracity of these Revelations
Phillip Schofield and Hugh Edge was were
not accused of illegality so I think
it's a different case uh a completely
different level with brand but do you
want to live in a country where people
who want to make accusations charges uh
allegations because they feel they've
suffered some terrible crime can't speak
out and they're gagged and we're not
allowed to discuss it no I mean that's
the difference
and the media coordinating a campaign
designed to get us talking about this
area here or not to get people talking
but to hold somebody powerful to account
yeah I mean I think the thing is this is
basically this is what this is the
result of me too metoo's done a lot of
really good things it stopped powerful
nasty men from taking advantage of
people who are in their throat has it
really I think it has yeah the real
world yeah I think it has I think well
certainly in my industry in newspapers
it's you know you're much less likely to
have any trouble maybe less likely but
it's not stopped no but it is I think
it's dramatically changed it is behavior
I think it really really has changed
Behavior I I think that the issue here
is that these allegations relate to 10
years ago okay I I'm not you know it's
very difficult with a passage of time to
prove any of this kind of stuff I think
that if women really I think they should
come forward and they should come
forward to the police and they should do
it as quickly as they can and I know
it's difficult because I know it's a
very emotional thing and I know all
sorts of things but the most important
thing is to come forward at every stage
and doing what this what's happening now
probably won't get them any justice okay
I've got to leave it there thank you
very much I appreciate it lots it's
complicated this stuff these are big
issues I think you raise a very good
point Chris I do think the biggest story
is exactly what you just identified
which is most people most women the vast
majority of the allegations they don't
have any justice even when even when the
evidence is overwhelming uh thank you
all three of you I appreciate it and
says the next millions of Russell Brand
supporters decry the case against him as
a conspiracy the world's richest man
Elon Musk is among them on debate with
one of the influences defending him next
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
coming up on the talk more women come
forward with allegations about the
comedian Russell Brand and as the
government bans Excel bullies shocking
videos show owners are turning their
dogs into weapons using sticks and
steroids and Lucy letby may have
murdered three more babies that's
according to one of the Witnesses in her
trial and that's all coming up at nine
[Music]
thank you welcome back to Facebook on
Saturday recent years Russell Brands
reinvented himself as Nancy
establishment commentator online he has
6.6 million subscribers on his YouTube
channel 11.2 million followers on
Twitter 6 million fans on Facebook and
they're all very loyal to it millions of
Brands fans have been crying conspiracy
since this Scandal bro led by
influential figures like Elon Musk
Jordan Peterson and Andrew Tay why do so
many believe that he's a victim of a big
conspiracy we'll discuss this I'm joined
by the controversial influencer Pearl
Davis I'm from New York the well equally
controversial influencer Louise makes
let's call you both the same title shall
we
um all right let me start with you Pearl
uh I've been watching this it's very
interesting how this debate has come
down now uh with a lot of people on the
conservative right in the main but
basically saying they believe he's been
deliberately targeted and taken down to
silence him because he's been promoting
what they see as conspiracy theories
I mean it certainly seems like that I
mean I think you just you just start to
see the same thing over and over again
where prominent figures like like the
Tate Brothers right come out and then
all of a sudden they have all these
allegations from 10 years ago and
there's no evidence they don't go to the
police and all of the sudden it's it's
believe women with no evidence
and you and and it becomes like trial by
the media which I just think is wrong
but is it right to equate
his YouTube channel his
you know exploration of various theories
about covid or whatever is it really
realistic that the four-year
investigation by two mainstream media
companies is in any way connected to
that or a desire to sign and say why
would they care
it just seems like they they always just
go after them I don't know why
all right let me bring in Louise I mean
I don't I don't really follow this
Theory because I don't understand why
mainstream media would really care if
Russell Brand has millions of people
that want to watch his stuff I mean I've
watched some on occasionally it's not
always right-wing people he has
left-wing people on as well
um it's quite interesting some of it uh
I was gonna get him on my show and maybe
do hit so I don't really understand this
theory that somehow it's all a
deliberate campaign to silence it
what did they have a time machine Pierce
like do they have a time machine to go
back in time four years before he had
this YouTube channel at all and before
he started tacking hard to the alt-right
and then somehow they decided that they
were going to get him no they didn't and
I think the key thing here is not to
confuse two separate issues the first is
the issue of putative criminality of a
criminal case that as your previous
guests said will almost certainly never
be brought because this is historical
stuff and saying which I think you're
saying I disagree with you that the rest
of us can't decide that these women are
victims now I don't believe in the metoo
movement I have a problem with the idea
that accusation is the same as
conviction that's not true I believe
these specific women because I heard
what they have to say and I find them
credible in a way that I don't find
other accusers credible and I think
that's the difference
then go to the police like why are you
going to the media not the police you
know I mean at the end of the day the
media like they run stories and I just
don't think it's fair that we do trial
by the media
um
Harvey Weinstein is in prison because
women went to journalists
and then the police they should go to
the police yeah but it can be very
Sometimes women feel we just have that
why would you that doesn't make any
sense you go to the journalists instead
of the police but we live in a country
here where only one percent of rape
allegations lead to conviction well
you're maybe only one percent were
telling the truth I don't know does that
seem likely could be
unlikely I don't know says to me the
justice system is wrong in the way we
investigate these things Louise
look Pearl is somebody who believes that
women shouldn't even have the vote okay
let's just let's just leave it there yes
you heard in your own show today on your
own show today appears one of your
earlier guests who was actually
defending Russell Brand said that she
had been raped and the police treated
her very nicely but when you pressed her
and said then what happened we heard
what happens all the time to women that
make these accusations the director of
public prosecution said there were two
people in the room I can't prove
anything and they didn't bother to bring
it together
I don't just see I don't think he's
assuming that I remember I disagree with
Louise I listen to them I don't think it
is sensible to automatically believe any
accusers about anything my natural
journalisty head says to me that's a
dangerous road to go down we've seen
timing again cases in this country where
people have been have turned out to be
completely innocent who were the subject
of massive publicity over bogus
allegations and you're telling me that a
guy that has women throwing themselves
at him 24 7 had to rape somebody that
doesn't make sense to me well I don't
think I don't think you can make the
leap that that couldn't happen I didn't
say it couldn't I'd say it's very
unlikely like it's Elon Musk is he gonna
rob a bank probably not I think it's
certainly less likely but he could do it
Louise final words here quick
he had thousands of women yeah but he
decided he had to go and pick up a 16
year old from school look I don't have
to see him convicted in a court of law
to believe these accusers because these
specific accusers are credible okay the
story is incredible why are they
credible we've got all over there
we will come back to this because it's
bound to keep going miss Scandal thank
you Pearl thank you Louise that's it for
me what you're up to keep it unsensitive
good night
thank you
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy latty will die Behind Bars and I've
seen a doctor who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
way TK team that would make her a better
princess of wealth delay Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I obviously wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election can we yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
let it roll
oh yeah